well as you may have noticed if you
listen to the show I don't really talk
much about impeachment on this show
mostly because the subject bores me
frankly and I'm not good at pretending
to be interested in things that I'm not
interested in that's one of the reasons
why I was really bad at customer service
jobs you know when I was a teenager
because you know someone comes into the
pizza place and says hmm
what pizza toppings do you recommend
that I get on my pizza I honestly don't
care I really don't care what pizza why
would I care what pizza toppings you get
on your pizza just hurry up in order you
glutton anyway so faking interest isn't
my strong suit
also it seems to me that this
impeachment is is for the most part
political theater and and not even very
entertaining political theater and never
was that clearer than yesterday when the
Dems called up a series of quote
witnesses who didn't witness anything
and of course at a legal sense what we
talked about witnesses doesn't have to
be in the sense that they actually
witnessed something but the fact remains
these are people who had no personal
knowledge of anything related to the
impeachment case they were college
professors college professors who were
all of course political partisans openly
hostile to the president and the only
moment of the testimony from them that
anyone's talking about today is this
line from a professor Pamela Carlin who
incidentally looks exactly like my 10th
grade math teacher and I think she looks
like everyone's 10th grade math teacher
I'm pretty sure but here's here's that
moment Kings could do no wrong because
the King's word was law and contrary to
what President Trump has said article 2
does not have give him the power to do
anything he wants and I'll just give you
one example that shows you the
difference between him and a king which
is the Constitution says there can be no
titles of nobility so while the
president can name his son Baron he
can't make him a baron I think I cringed
so hard at that joke that I broke a rib
I think and you know she had that line
planned for months probably she thought
that one she wrote it down on a note
card she said oh this is good this is
good she practiced it in a mirror 40
times she was thinking that it would
absolutely kill and then and then and
then she delivers it and she gets this
awkward pause followed by and it's even
what's worse than the awkward pause
after a joke is the polite chuckle that
she got from a few of the polite
sympathetic chuckle that she got from a
few people in the room in fairness in an
impeachment hearing is kind of a tough
venue for a comedy routine so I think it
would be hard to make your material land
no matter how good it is but this
material would bomb anywhere and I say
this by the way is a huge apologist for
and fan of puns I have no problem with
puns I love puns I will defend puns to
my dying breath it's just that this pun
was punishingly bad I'm sorry had to
throw that in there and and and this is
this is all there really is to say about
that joke it's cringy corny lame like
the one that i just did it all puns tend
to be but this was I think a few levels
beyond that and the fact that these
people are coming to the hearing with
lines like that ready to go only proves
again that this is all performative it's
all theatre and I think that should be
our focus we should focus on that rather
than as conservatives engaging in our
own performance pretending to be
offended by the dumb joke that this lady
told
unfortunately a lot of Republicans and
conservatives today and yesterday have
chosen the latter course pretending to
be offended by it in fact the only I
only heard about this joke because a
bunch of conservatives on social media
were angry
shouting about a Dem impeachment witness
who attacked the child
attacked a minor attacked the
president's child and and so on someone
actually said on on on Twitter I saw
they said someone said something like
she went on an unhinged rant against a
child
attacking the child and I heard all this
and I said wow maybe what did this woman
say she really should attacked it so
then I watched the clip and know
obviously she didn't attack Barron Trump
there's no attack here well what exactly
is the attack her she's saying that
Trump can't make his own son of Baron
that's not an attack on the son
obviously that's a criticism of the
president not of the president's child
but we all know that right we all know
that she didn't attack the kid nobody's
really outraged about it or offended but
some people on the right are pretending
to be and this is this is a troubling
trend that I've noticed on the right now
we know about the fake outrage on the
left they do it all the time and I talk
about it all the time I think it's
becoming more and more common on the
right and I'm really not a fan of it
because I hate fake outrage on either
side I think it's pitiful it's pathetic
it's lame I don't think it accomplishes
whatever you think it's going to
accomplish when you engage in it but
some people on the right have have
decided that the best way to beat the
left is to act like a fainting damsel in
distress at every opportunity someone
today I was talking about this someone
told me that well we're fighting back
this is us fighting you're fighting by
crying about a joke that's you that's
that's you being a warrior that's you
fighting no that's you being a wimp okay
it's you acting like a wuss that's also
you undermining everything you've ever
said about how the left are a bunch of
snowflakes who overreact and so on and
so forth
so I don't think that we fight by doing
that I think I think we just become the
very thing that we're fighting which is
a profoundly bad strategy it's also
embarrassing and pathetic and especially
to see men see grown men so some grown
men on Twitter why I never this joke was
just way out of bounds I just am so
offended by this I mean the fact that
you're doing it online means you don't
have to keep the straight face but I
just I guess I can sort of respect it if
you could keep a straight face while
pretending to be offended by that some
other people said that she invaded
barons privacy in vain
is privacy by saying his name he's the
president's kid everybody knows his name
it's not an invasion of privacy it's a
it's a fact we all know what his name is
we don't need to reach for some way to
make the joke into a crime against
humanity we don't have to desperately
grasp for a reason to be offended
I think the much better course really so
if we could choose between being
fainting damsels in distress on our
fainting couches just you know
collapsing at home my goodness if we
could choose between that or being
immature trolls mocking this woman for a
bad joke I would say let's go with the
immature troll rapped that's better
let's go with that it's a corny lame
joke and that should be our point and we
should leave it there and then get back
to the bigger point of course which is
that this is all political theater and
this is an example of that I think I
think I think that's what we should be
that's what we should be focused on all
right by the way you know giving holiday
gifts is great and the only thing though
is overspending on all those gifts is
definitely not great so why spend more
than you have to finding the lowest
price is easy if you have honey honey is
a free browser extension emphasis on
free you don't if you caught that part
that automatically finds the best promo
codes whenever you shop online I can
tell you that I use honey for all of my
Christmas gifts and for all the
Christmas shopping that I did and I
saved a ton of money that way look if
you're gonna you're gonna be spending
money around the holidays no way around
it so why spend more than you have to is
the point and that's why I used honey
honey has found it's over ten million
members over a billion dollars in
savings honey supports over 20,000
stores online if you're buying gifts
this holiday season then you need honey
if you're not you probably know someone
who is so you could do them a solid and
tell them about honey honey could help
say help make sure that you're getting
the best price for whatever you're
buying it's free to use it installs in
just two clicks
there's just no reason not to use it get
honey for free adjoin
honey dot-com / Walsh that's join honey
dot-com / Walsh okay well if you want to
see identity politics at its most
hilariously confused then let's check in
with a meeting of beat Pete but a judge
supporters I'm gonna show you the video
in a minute just a little bit of setup
here this is a meeting held by black
leaders in South Bend Indiana and their
rallying support trying to rally support
specifically in the black community for
mayor Pete's presidential run
well black lives matter showed up and
they weren't happy about this you see
the they don't like Pete Buddha judge
recently we talked about a little bit
but he's gotten himself in trouble on on
the racial stuff especially last week
when an old video surfaced of him if you
can believe it
claiming that there's an issue in the
inner city with kids growing up without
role models which is one of those
obviously correct observations that
apparently you're not allowed to say
anymore it'll make you racist so Pete
Buddha judge said that a few years ago
and it's one of the reasons why BLM and
and those folks don't like him so they
showed up and they weren't happy they
say that these black leaders aren't real
black leaders they're not qualified for
that position they don't speak for the
black community but see if you can if
you notice I think I'll play this clip
for you see if you notice something a
little bit strange about the BLM
activist who is making this point
there's something kind of conspicuous
about him and see if you notice it watch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
actually wait hang on a second before we
get to the main point here can we go
back very quickly to 223 in that 23 to
27 in that video 23 seconds 27 seconds I
want to focus on that for a minute let's
let's watch that moment one more time
okay yeah that's what I thought that's
yes that's that's an elderly woman
running up with a cane to smack the BLM
guy with her cane but she was restrained
by the audience that I just checked you
I want to make sure that I saw that
right and yeah that is what happened
there which is which of course is
awesome
meanwhile the BLM guy who's stealing the
microphone from black woman and claiming
that she isn't a real black leader is
not himself black that's the conspicuous
detail here I'm not gonna make any
assumptions about what his race or
ethnicity is other than to say that he
definitely is not a black man I think
that much is clear so to review this is
a non black man stealing the microphone
from black supporters of a gay
Democratic presidential candidate how do
you even begin to do the intersectional
math here it's it gets very confusing
and this is one of the reasons why the
left is imploding gloriously before our
eyes because the identity politics math
has become so confused they've long
since determined of course that ideas
don't matter the truth doesn't matter
forget about that all that matters is
jockeying for
position the scrambling for victimhood
status the placing of people into
categories based on their race ethnicity
gender sexuality and so on but there are
so many categories now and we've been
divided in so many ways that it's just
chaos
I've talked many times about the
victimhood hierarchy on the left the
victimhood pyramid well it seems the
pyramid is crumbling and and and this is
the result this is really no different
than well think about what was at the at
the Democrat town hall on CNN a few
months ago where you had a quote trans
woman that is a man stealing the
microphone from a woman an actual woman
to go on a rant about how he's being
marginalized marginalized and so on so
we're used to seeing that we've been
seeing that on the left now for years
and I have talked about it plenty of
times how these men these gender
confused men are taking or superseding
or taking precedence over women but this
is one of the first times I can think of
where you've got a certainly a non black
guy coming in and just boldly taking the
microphone from Oh from a black woman
not just taking the microphone from her
but taking it from her so that he can
talk about race issues so that he can be
the one to talk about the situation that
the black community is in Wow
speaking of of disarray on the Left
here's one other example I don't mean to
go backwards but this related to
impeachment this is representative Al
Green I'm gonna play this for you
although he's a Democrat you know he's
got a problem with the way the
impeachment hearings are going and and
maybe you can guess what his problem is
going to be watch Mr Speaker I rise
because I love my country but I also
rise today with heartfelt regrets it
hurts my heart mr. speaker
to see the Judiciary Committee hearing
experts on the topic of impeachment one
of the seminal issues of this Congress
hearing experts mr. speaker and not one
person of color among the experts what
subliminal message are we sending to the
world when we have experts but not one
person of color are we saying that there
are no people of color who are experts
on this topic of impeachment what is the
message that we're sending mr. speaker
if I am wrong I will apologize but if
the committee is wrong if the Congress
is wrong what will it do mr. speaker
people of color for too long have been
ignored by one party and taken for
granted by the other too often this
happens not always but too often it
happens mr. speaker I refuse to be
ignored and taken for granted I came
here to represent the people who are
ignored and taken for granted
yeah actually al you're in Congress to
represent the ninth District of Texas
that's who you're supposed to represent
just to be clear white and black but Al
Green is worried not that the
constitutional experts might not be
experts not that there might be
something wrong with her testimony but
that they don't have the right skin
pigmentation he's worried that the
supposed to expert testimony will be
coming out of the mouths of people whose
skin tone is too light for his taste but
that's not racist remember it's not
racist somehow now if
if the if the people giving the
testimony were all non-white and then a
white guy got up there and said we need
a white person on there to hear from
them that would be racist right but when
our green does it's not racist just so
you know I mean it is racist of course
it's definitely racist but we're not
supposed to notice that all right moving
on I want to take a look at it at a
piece in The New York Times that I've
had on the docket here to talk about for
a few days now the piece written by
Bradley Onishi title is could I be my
own soul mate maybe Emma Watson and Liz
oh are onto something
doubtful it's doubtful they're onto
something but let's find out reading a
little bit now from the article it says
in a recent interview for British Vogue
the actress Emma Watson raised some
eyebrows when she described herself as
self partnered she's approaching 30 and
according to miss Watson it took much
hard work to recognize that being signal
single and without children doesn't
signal failure it just means that she is
going on her journey of self fulfillment
and discovery alone and that's okay miss
Watson is not the only person to
describe herself and her relationship
status in such terms Liz oh the wrapper
and flautist who is she is that okay who
went from underground start a mainstream
darling the summer proclaims in her song
soulmate quote I'm my own soul mate I
know how to love me I know that I'm
always gonna hold me down
that's just poetry isn't it those are
just those are brilliant lyrics I my own
soul mate I know how to love me I know
that I'm always gonna hold me down is
that even are we sure that that's Liz oh
and not Shakespeare that sounds like
something straight from from Bill
Shakespeare I don't know
apparently tired of looking for the one
Liz oh realised it was her all along for
most people the idea of self coupling
may be jarring but a closer look might
reveal it to be more of an end point of
a trend marriage rates have been
declining steadily since the 1970s many
of us are dating more but somehow going
on fewer dates sex is safer and less
burdened with che
in the past and seemingly more available
but we're having less of it than we were
a generation ago and despite all these
mixed signals most of us are still
looking for the one and then it goes on
from there
this does not mean that seeing oneself
as one's own partner or soulmate is
equivalent to loneliness while
loneliness is an epidemic and numerous
developed countries including parts the
United States the self coupling Miss
Watson and Liz O reference is not the
same thing as social isolation it does
not preclude meaningful relationships of
all types okay
so you get the idea loving yourself
being your own soul mate a few problems
here most of them are probably pretty
obvious the first is that love is in its
it's love requires in other okay because
because love is an act love is not just
a feeling
in fact feelings are many times
irrelevant to love you think about all
the people close to you in your life
especially if you're married if you have
kids you're you're not going to every
second of the day 100% of the time have
warm and fuzzy feelings about those
people okay
because you're gonna be angry with them
sometimes you're gonna be annoyed you're
gonna be stressed out drained all that
so what do we if love is just a feeling
then do we say you're in those moments
as a parent when you are just ticked off
of your kids and you don't want to be
around them you just need some space
does does that mean you don't love them
in those but of course you love them and
that's because now if love is just a
feeling then I guess we would have to
say that your love for them in those
moments is a little bit less than in the
moments where you have warm and fuzzy
feelings but that's not the case because
we know that love is deeper than that
love is an act of will it's a choice it
is a thing you do it is sacrifice and
why when it comes down to it the idea of
loving yourself even putting aside this
dumb stuff about self partnering being
your own soulmate I think most people
with two brain cells know that that's
ridiculous but let let's I think a lot
of people would say oh yeah itself
partnered is stupid being your own
soulmate is kind of dumb but of course
you need to love yourself no I would
argue actually that loving yourself is
meaningless IIIi would actually say that
you shouldn't love yourself or you
shouldn't try to or at least that it
doesn't really mean anything when it
comes down to it I think the idea of
loving yourself is meaningless everyone
says you have to love yourself but but
what do they really mean by that what
does it consist of what is this what do
you when you tell me I should love
myself okay well what should I be doing
exactly what if you tell me I should
love my wife well I know exactly what
what what that's all about
I could start talking about what loving
your spouse consists of and it's gonna
be a lot of and almost everything I say
is going to be action based loving
yourself though I mean you can you can
love someone else by taking care of them
giving to them giving of yourself to
them and that's what loving someone else
is all about right but giving to
yourself and giving of yourself to
yourself and caring for yourself
okay well that's either simple
self-preservation which is fine we do
need to take care of ourselves it's not
that's not about love when you go and
you're thirsty you take a drink of water
is that an act of self-love I'm so in
love with myself give me the water no
it's just you do because you have to you
want to live so on one in the spectrum
taking care of yourself giving to
yourself is self-preservation on the
other end of the spectrum
it could be selfishness where you're
giving to yourself too much and you're
too focused on yourself but what is
have to do with any of that to quote the
song what does love have to do with it I
mean what what does love have to do with
any of that lizzo says I'm always gonna
hold me down well okay but that's
because you care about your own
interests it's not it's not Noble you
can't try to make that into some noble
act well I'm always gonna hold myself
down yeah that's that's that's that's
not love it's that's natural it's even
healthy to a certain degree you're
taking care of your own interest it's
not love though now holding someone else
down
ie taking care of them that is that's
love what about feelings well as I
already said feelings are have almost
nothing to do with love but to whatever
extent that they are involved okay well
if you if you love someone else then
most of the time you're gonna feel
affectionate towards them what does it
mean to be affectionate towards yourself
okay when when I
my children most of the time it can have
the effect of warning of warming my my
cold icy heart gonna be very
heartwarming and put a smile on my face
so I have a feeling of love and
affection for my children but wouldn't I
be a narcissist if I stared in the
mirror and just was felt my heart warm
at my own reflection I mean I could look
at my kids who are you know playing when
they're when they're playing nicely with
each other or you know they're being
well behaved and they're just being cute
little kids and I can look at them and
yeah of a smile on my face and it's just
in and and I enjoy sort of just seeing
that seeing the kids being kids
well wouldn't I be a narcissist if I
could just sit for 15 minutes staring at
my reflection my heart sufficiently
warmed by it now sure we should have a
certain amount of confidence and
self-awareness but that's not love or
self self assurance I'm self-awareness
too but self assured so if you want to
talk about confidence self assurance
fine but again that's not love that's
just confidence and self-assurance so
where does the love come in I don't know
when when when does that ever help and
it doesn't matter anyway
because this is what I always say
there's way too much focus on how we
feel about ourselves and getting our
feelings about ourselves right and
people say really dumb stuff like well
I've got to work on loving myself first
before I can love anyone else no wrong
that is totally wrong and if you go into
a marriage or a relationship with an
attitude like that it's gonna fail
that's the worst possible attitude what
does that mean you can't love anyone
else until you love yourself what kind
of a selfish bastard are you I mean
that's would you say that to your would
you say that to your kids oh sorry I
can't love you today because I'm not
really loving myself yeah I'm just I'm
not
feeling myself day so I can't love you
kids sorry I'm gonna go sit in a corner
and and really work on feeling good
about myself and once I get there and
come inland and and and you know show
love to you well what an absolutely
horrible way to to approach
relationships no I think the best thing
is maybe we should all stop worrying so
much about how we feel about ourselves
if we could stop when we just stop for
five minutes if we could all pull this
off and it's difficult for all of us
myself included but if for five minutes
we could just stop worrying about how we
feel about ourselves rather than sitting
there how do I feel about myself how am
i how are my feelings towards myself am
i confident in myself do I love myself
how about just five minutes shut up with
that forget about it
who cares how you feel about yourself
and go live your life live outwardly
look at the world out there there's a
lot of stuff going on there people the
you know people that depend on you you
have a family of friends you got a life
you have a job go go go for a walk I
mean go look at the trees in the sky I
mean look at anything else aside from
yourself you're from your own reflection
think about that maybe that's the the
key here rather than focusing all the
time
on our feelings about ourselves I I
submit that if somebody lived their
whole life never worrying about loving
themselves just no concept of that not
concerned about it but they love other
people I I submit that that would be a
fulfilling well lived life at the end of
it on the other hand
who spends a whole life just working on
loving themselves well that at the end
of their life they're gonna realize that
they've done nothing they've
accomplished nothing
they've just been focused and obsessed
with themselves the entire time and they
were they live their life like this
black hole that just sucks everything
into itself no light can escape all
right so as it turns out maybe the
self-help advice of Liz oh isn't quite
as stellar as maybe the media imagines
you know leftists have taken over the
culture in Hollywood in academia even
online and it's dangerous because they
want to shut down open debate well
starring Adam Carolla Dennis Prager no
safe spaces isn't is in theaters on
Friday December 6th so that's coming up
what that's coming up tomorrow Adam and
Dennis take out a wild ride to show you
the effects of political correctness
identity politics cancel culture the
film takes you through the impact on
college campuses big tech in Hollywood
no safe spaces shows us why free speech
is important to a free society how its
being threatened and what we can do
importantly to fight back it's not your
typical documentary it has animation
recreations plenty of Adam Carolla's
signature humor to help the medicine go
down no safe spaces takes you behind the
scenes of Ben Shapiro's riot filled trip
to UC Berkeley the god-king of daily
wire has a cameo and even I'm in the
film for a moment if you can find me
I'll send Prager to your house to wash
your car apparently no safe space is
rated pg-13 in theaters Friday November
December 6th go to no safe spaces
dot-com slash Walsh for ticket
information and theater locations that's
no safe spaces dot-com slash Walsh for
ticket information and theater locations
ok um let's go to emails Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com this is from Andrew says hi
Matt I was hoping you could touch touch
on one of the most underreported
embarrassments of our time I see people
breakfast Breck and it sickens me and
makes me yearn for the cold embrace of
death with these people be tortured to
death under your regime or just killed
as fast as possible brekkie what BR e
kkae why so you have grown it now are
these grown adults are we talking about
nine year old saying this if you're
telling me grown men are referring to
their breakfast as brekkie dear god it's
worse than I thought this this is even
worse than I was talking to somebody a
little while ago grown man and and in
fact we were talking about it I was in
his house and we were talking about his
couch which is very comfortable couch
and any time I said on a comfortable
couch I always remark on the fact that
it's a comfortable couch but he doesn't
call it comfortable he calls it comfy
this is a grown man using the word comfy
oh it's so comfy my god no if you're a
grown man you say comfortable not comfy
and you say vegetable not veggies
brekkie is just that's that is a crime
that is I can't even put it into words
I refuse to believe it I need exam I
refuse to believe that there are grown
men saying brekkie for breakfast I need
examples of that because I just I don't
believe I refute I do believe it but I
refuse to if that makes sense this is
from Jane says hi Matt I think you were
way too harsh on the woman who emailed
about her adult son who lives at home
your solution was basically for her to
just kick his butt to the curb yeah but
I think this condescension for people
like you to people who live with their
parents has really misplaced in some
cultures families lived together for
many generations you'll have many
generations under one roof there isn't
anything necessarily wrong with living
with your parents I would think I would
I would think someone like yourself who
pretends to be pro-family would be in
favor of families sticking together
well Jane I think family sticking
together is a great thing
what you're talking about is not
extended adolescence where a grown man
continues living off of his parents
depend it upon them well into his 30s
you're not talking about a situation
where a 30 year old man is still living
as if he's 14 that was this specific
situation I was asked about it was a
grown adult who wasn't working wasn't
contributing was hanging out in his room
all day while his parents support him
that's not traditional that's not
cultural that's not pro-family that's a
grown adult being a leech and taking
advantage of his parents now a situation
where multiple generations live together
they all contribute they all are active
and present and contributing members of
the family fine I'm the problem with
that if you want to go back and talk
about the old agrarian societies where
you would have the the sons would would
live on the farm still and with their
wives and families and they would work
the farm fantastic I think it would be
great if more people live that way
there's a part of me that would like to
live that way myself but that's entirely
different
obviously but from an adult who plays
video games all day well as mommy and
daddy pay for his food clothing shelter
and everything else then you could
clearly see the difference right this is
from Jarkko says hello master of dry wit
how can it be possible that voters are
called racist because of Camela dropping
when everyone knows Michelle would win
if she wanted to run I'm not from the
USA so I don't know are people really
blind to this or is it just a media
thing by the way Camilla means horrible
in Finnish thank you would take care
does it really mean that that's pretty
pretty awesome yeah well right that's
just another example we talked about
this yesterday there were some people in
the media trying to claim that Camilla
didn't get any traction for a campaign
because of racism and there are many
reasons why that's an absurd claim you
point out Michelle Michelle Obama yes I
and I think this is pretty conventional
wisdom that if Michelle Obama did jump
into the to the race which I guess it's
unlikely that she would but if she did
she would immediately
the front-runner as a black woman but we
don't even need to talk about Michelle
Obama because her husband a black man
was president for eight years he won the
term in office and then won another one
so that should really put it to rest
right there
the idea that Kamala Harris didn't get
traction because of her race meanwhile
the last president we had was black yeah
that's gonna be a difficult case to make
this is from Amy says Matt I hope this
question is not too personal I've been
dating my boyfriend for three years
we're both 27 I love him and wants to
spend my life with him but he still has
not proposed we both have good jobs
financially we're in a good spot I don't
see any reason why we shouldn't be
engaged by now I've jumped all I've
dropped all the hints you mentioned on
your show a few weeks ago but either he
hasn't picked up on it or he just
doesn't want to get married what do you
think is three years enough time
am I wrong for expecting proposal by now
yeah three years is more than enough
time Amy I have to tell you at the age
of 27 now if you started dating when you
were 15 and be different but three years
I mean three months honestly three
months is enough by three months you
know up I put it another way I think
it's pretty rare that you'll meet
someone who was dating someone for three
months and didn't think they were
marriage material at all and then eight
months later had changed their mind that
usually doesn't happen and in fact
that's one of the reasons why people
talk about Oh was love at first sight
well a lot of at first sight of course
doesn't exist there's no way that you
could except in the in the in the
general kind of way that we're supposed
to love all mankind I guess you could
love a person at first sight in that way
but in any kind of deeper sense it
obviously isn't possible that you could
really come to love someone in that way
when you just first saw them what you're
calling love at first sight in that case
is just you found them attractive but I
think one of the reasons why you know if
you talk to someone who's been married
for 40 years and they'll say uh you know
it was love it
site well I think what they're really
expressing is that they knew very early
on that this is someone they wanted to
marry it's just it it wasn't literally
the first second they saw them but it
doesn't take long and it definitely
doesn't doesn't take three years if
you've been with someone for three years
and you're still not sure if you want to
marry them then it's not gonna work and
you shouldn't marry them that's that's
my feeling about it so yeah I think
you're right to expect it and what I
would say is if you haven't talked to
him directly about it you say you've
dropped hints well I would have a really
frank conversation with him about it and
forget about all the hints just sit down
and say listen this is my life too and
if this thing isn't going anywhere I
don't want I don't want to date for
another five years for no reason and
next thing you know I'm you know 33
years old and and then we're breaking up
I want to do that so I would sit down
and have a frank conversation when I'm
not saying just throw throw them out
right away but I would if you have not
had a direct conversation I would have
it and if it's clear that in that and I
think it will be clear one way or
another if it's clear in that
conversation that he's just not looking
to get married or well then I think
probably you got to cut your losses all
right finally this is from Stephen says
oh great and wise leader who bequeaths
truth wisdom and punishment in the show
in which you talk about people eating
dogs you made a comment about how all
animals deserve respect I think everyone
would agree that it would be sick to go
around poaching penguins in a city or
squash and lizards out of pure joy but I
do not understand where the distinction
lies depending upon which type of animal
that you speak of personally I enjoy
killing some types of animals at a pure
recreation at the angst of my wife I
purchased a $45 plastic gun that shoots
granular salt and is designed to kill
house flies mosquitoes etc it is so fun
that sometimes I will go so far as to
set a bait of raw chicken scraps to
attract flies and then I'll just have a
shootout for hours upon end I also enjoy
watching the ants come and drag away the
carcasses of the dead flies as some of
the abdomens of said flies spew out live
larvae the desperate two
scape their doom I've even elevated my
attack to wasps encroaching upon my home
which is an entirely new level of risk
and adventure I think it is easy to draw
the distinction between house flies bees
and small birds or lizards but obviously
but obviously there is a plethora of
animal of complexity in between these
two categories in which the line begin
to blur between what is socially
acceptable behavior and what is
sociopathic am i a sociopath for
enjoying the murder of house flies or a
valiant warrior defending humanity
against insect invasion during your
fascist rule what sort of punishment or
praise would be bestowed upon an
individual such as myself when you
started getting into enjoying the ants
dragging away the carcasses that was a
little serial-killer ee okay I got a
little bit of a serial killer vibe there
just a little bit nothing to worry about
too much I'm saying you might have a
little bit of serial killer and you just
up just a smidge a tad so you know not a
big deal it may be like you might be 1%
serial killer I think it becomes a
problem when you get to 5% but stay stay
in the 1 2 3 rage and I think you'll be
alright but the bigger news here is
you're saying that they that there
exists on the market a plastic gun that
shoots table salt and kills flies that's
a thing that exists in the world that's
the news I hadn't know that I had no
idea that existed and now I know exactly
what I want for Christmas that is
awesome that's amazing I've always
wanted something like that and you know
why I want it I want it I'm with you for
the most part I'm with you on this
totally and I want it yeah because for
the recreation also for justice because
so many times you know when you've got a
fly problem and you just get angry at
the Flies and you feel like I need to
punish these flies this this is about
justice they have no right to be in my
home they have no right to fly around on
my food yeah no I really do want that
where it was so what is that called
please tell me it's called an assault
rifle to help please tell me that's what
they call it if it's not an assault
rifle then that was a missed opportunity
of the age
but that's that's amazing and no I think
it's great I think I think you got to
kill the Flies anyway you're protecting
it's not so much that you're protecting
humanity you're protecting your family
because mosquitoes flies these are
disease carrying creatures and you are
defending your family I think it sounds
like you said your your wife is not a
fan of it well I think that your wife
should it have more gratitude for what
you're doing you're putting yourself in
harm's way you know again flies carry
diseases mosquitoes could have malaria
and what you're doing is you are
valiantly stepping in front of your wife
and your children if you have any and
saying no I will shield you I will
protect you and you're charging into
battle to go to war against these
against these plague carrying beasts and
your wife has the audacity to complain
about it it's amazing to me as far as
the question of well that's that's
pretty much all that needs to be said
about it I suppose as far as the
question on a slightly more serious
level although I am entirely serious
about wanting this this this gun on a
slightly more serious level I do think
that when we talk about animals and how
animals should be treated and even which
ones should be eaten and which ones not
and that sort of thing I do think part
of what we're weighing here is the
capacity that these creatures have for
suffering and that's gonna have a lot to
do with their consciousness of course we
can't know exactly what sort of
consciousness any animal has because we
can't be inside their minds but it I
think it stands to reason I think we all
sort of assume for good reason that dogs
have a in terms of the animal kingdom
have a pretty high capacity for
consciousness and therefore for
suffering and that's why yeah if there's
a dog on your property not just going to
shoot it flies
on the other hand I think again we don't
really know but they probably have
almost no capacity for suffering or none
at all they probably have basically no
consciousness and so I don't think you
have to worry too much about it
I wouldn't torture them like I wouldn't
capture one and tie it down and tear its
wings off to try to get it to talk and
tell your words friends are I wouldn't
do that but I think a shot of salt to
the to the brain is to the to the fly
brain is a quick and painless death
probably better than these flies deserve
to be frank with you
all right and so thanks for thanks that
email thanks for letting me know about
that awesome product I will go look it
up right now and thanks everybody for
watching and listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there